hey youtubers it's Charlie a whole bunch
of DC stuff happening today in the TV
universe so they had a big legends of
tomorrow flash and arrow panel this is
gonna be all about the flash I'll do an
arrow video after this but they just
announced Kevin Smith is gonna be
directing in episode 1 of the final
episodes of the flash this season if you
don't know what the TCAs are they're
basically like a big convention for
television critics it's an industry
event where television networks explain
what's going on with all their TV shows
CW has four different DC shows on its
roster there's arrow the flash legends
of tomorrow and then there's the vixen
animated series which you guys might not
know about they did confirm that that's
getting a second series and vixen is
going to go on arrow and I'll talk a
little bit more about that during my
arrow Felicity Smoak video later tonight
there's a whole bunch of arrow specific
stuff going on but let's talk about
Kevin Smith doing the flash is actually
it's kind of funny I laughed a little
bit because he's been talking so much
about the flash season 1 he's one of
those Hollywood guys that's participated
in a lot of comic book projects being
attached to big film comic book projects
written comic books but just doesn't
watch a whole lot of TV so hearing him
talk about the TV shows is little bit
funny for me he has a Batman podcast
that he does and on it before he said
that Jason Mewes you know of Jay and
Silent Bob is just like the craziest TV
person watches like every single show
you could possibly imagine and bugs him
all the time to watch the flash and all
these are the shows so Kevin Smith
relented started watching the flash fell
in love with it being someone who's a
producer of films and television shows
without like a crazy number of projects
going on right now it makes sense that
he would try to do an episode of the
flash at some point I'm surprised it
hasn't happened yet so here's the thing
though they did say the episode would
come in May they didn't say which number
it's gonna be but if the schedule for
airing episodes this year is pretty
similar to last year then that would put
episodes 21 to 23 the finale in May
meaning that he'll definitely be
directing one of those last couple of
episodes so last year episode 21 was
Grodd lives that was the big gorilla
grodd episode that introduced him in a
really big way episode 22 was the big
rogue escape episode in episode 23 was
the finale my big question that I had
right after they announced the news was
would they actually let him direct the
finale without ever having to
rekted an episode of the flash before he
hasn't worked with any of the flash
people before the finales are usually
like an all-hands-on-deck type of
situation so they'll probably try and
play it safe in terms of the people that
they hire to make the finale episode
Pete you know people that have proven
that they're awesome at directing flash
episodes but I think they'll do with
Kevin Smith though being that he's a
really good director has a really firm
understanding of this comic book
universe in the tone of the flash is
they'll give him an episode where they
do a really big comic book character but
one that isn't going to make or break
the season like I think a really good
example is is if you guys ever watch
Smallville there was an episode of
Smallville that Geoff Johns wrote it was
the légion episode he did the Legion of
super-heroes really important group of
characters from the comics but the
episode itself wasn't a finale it wasn't
a premiere it was just somewhere in the
middle it was just intended to be this
really awesome episode by itself so
things gonna be the same situation with
Kevin Smith where it's like they do a
really big flash based character but
it's not gonna be the finale they also
confirmed that flash arrow characters
are totally gonna crossover with legends
of tomorrow that's not really news we
kind of knew that was going to happen
but they did say because legends of
tomorrow is a time travel based show
it's really hard to weave the narrative
together with arrow and flash so I think
they're mostly going to let the
characters cross over without letting
the specific plots cross over so for
example when flash characters cross over
to legends of tomorrow they're not going
to be doing zoom type things the flash
characters will just be helping with
whatever the plot is for legends of
tomorrow I'll talk about it a little bit
more during my legends of tomorrow video
but they did say you know one of the fun
things to look forward to is seeing
older and younger versions of Barry and
Oliver which i think is cool we've seen
a younger version of Barry we've seen
kid Barry several times but we haven't
seen an older version of Barry the one
that the reverse-flash grew to hate
reverse-flash of course totally coming
back in episode 11 the title of that
episode is the reverse-flash returns
which i think is kind of a lame title
but he gets the idea across
reverse-flash coming back it's gonna be
awesome one thing they really haven't
addressed yet that I'm looking forward
to in the back half is them actually
going to earth - there's gonna be a lot
more earth - stuff happening and not
just in flashbacks in present-day
what I'm hoping they do is a spin-off
comic that ties in with the TV show
based on earth-2 stories like they
explain what's going on on earth - they
provide some more context you guys may
heard that John Barrowman Malcolm Merlyn
from arrow is writing a comic book
that's going to explain what happened to
Malcolm Merlyn between seasons three and
four it's a Merlyn comic book set in the
air overs it'll drop weekly it'll be
cheaper than a normal comic because it's
coming every single week and I think the
first issue drops on the 13th they did
they didn't say anything about a new
flash comic they introduced king shark
in the flash season zero comic book that
was the one that tied it in with the TV
show last year hopefully they'll
continue that but I really want to see
them use it to tell more earth-2 stories
and when I say earth-2 I mean earth 2 of
the TV show there is a DC earth 2 comic
book but it's very different it's
something that's very very different
there's gonna be a whole lot more Wally
West week week i think wally west is
gonna be in every single episode for the
rest of the season and just like last
year with us learning more about eobard
thawne week to week I think we're gonna
be learning more about zoom but I don't
think we're gonna see him pull the mask
off and find out who he really is until
the last couple of episodes zoom wants
to be the fastest speedster he wants to
take Barry's speed but we don't know why
it's silly to think that he wants to be
fast just for the sake of being fast
clearly he wants the speed to achieve
some insurmountable goal but we don't
know what that is that's really what
they're gonna tease out over the back
half of the season
why is zoom so intent on killing other
speedsters in taking their speed just a
circle back around let me know in the
comments though what you know what do
you think about Kevin Smith directing an
episode of the flash which one do you
think I'll end up being will it be
episode 21 22 where do you think they
actually will give him the finale just a
tease something Andrew Kreisberg the
showrunner the flash said something
about this year he said that in the
season 1 finale when we see the Barry
with the white logo tell Barry of season
1 don't save your mother you know you
can't you can't save her you have to let
her die he said that we would travel
back to that moment we would learn more
about what's going on with that other
version of the flash so I think based on
what they've done with a costume so far
this year this is our version of the
flash in season 2 season 2 flash telling
season 1 flash no you can't save your
mother but the next question is is why
does season 2 Barry have to go back to
stop himself the way they play with time
can be a little confusing
which is why my end my legends of
tomorrow video I'll explain a little bit
about how they're handling
the rules of time-travel they have like
their own rules that they establish in
the pilot episode so right away you will
totally understand why they make certain
decisions giveaway time I will say
congratulations to Eric foo Gary you win
the reverse flash ring for this week
I'll start a new round of the giveaway
whenever I post my arrow video or later
tonight and I'll be talking all about
that felicity smoak promo that's going
around I'll say right now is that
anybody who has watched The Walking Dead
knows not to take trailers at face value
so why you guys wait for me to finish
that arrow video you can click here to
learn all about king shark coming back
in episode 15 of the flash and you can
click here for that Batman do you
believe teaser from last night thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight